[Music]
[Applause]
uh reggie miller the hall of famer
turner sports is not going to know what
uh game reggie's going to have until
later today
so we'll just have to sit here and wait
with reggie to find out
where he's going to be coming up here uh
how was the weekend uh happy belated
mother's day
to you and yours and all my danettes and
everyone
our viewers watching or listening abroad
and at home
yeah happy mother's day yeah well
because you got the uh the newborn there
so
we didn't even made it just that bit
extra special to uh to celebrate
mother's day i'm i'm very lucky
all right i got a couple of questions
here let me start with with steph
something that you uh are well versed in
these shots degree of difficulty here
reg like
i i it's hard to say that i'm i
i'm surprised or amazed when i tune in
to see steph i
i would have thought i've seen
everything how how do you describe this
run that he's had here
um in the last month or so i'm surprised
and amazed
that's what i'm gonna say and this is
coming from
a guy who i felt that i've seen
everything yeah
and i agree with you the degree of
difficulty
and time and score when he's making some
of these shots
it's sometimes head scratching and
you know for a guy who put a lot of time
and effort into my craft
hours and hours into gyms shooting
different shots from different locations
[Music]
you know being off balance having
contact
shooting shots i know how difficult it
can be
he has made it look like it's like he's
shooting at free throw and that's what
makes
people like myself somewhat amazed
because i know how difficult it is
so i i am amazed and people ask me about
mvps
he won't win the mvp but in my opinion
he should be in the top he should be in
the top three
for what he has done and what golden
state has done
no one really had especially when clay
went down everyone thought this was a
a straight line to the lottery once
again
give steve kerr and staff credit and i
give draymond green and especially steph
curry a lot of credit
for hanging in there playing with a
young team you lose your
second round draft pick james wiseman a
month and a half ago
and you have still found a way to be
competitive
and you're in the playoff hunt it's
amazing what he is doing
and if you get in that play in game with
the lakers
like that's really flirting with danger
if you're the lakers
um it is you know especially against a
player like steph
yeah who can get hot and it doesn't
matter if he's at home or on the road
his ability to make shots okay but the
lakers take down the suns
i don't know how important that game is
i don't know how big it was to you but
just
you know we we keep thinking that the
lakers and nets just go into the
playoffs and then everything's going to
be fine
you've had i'm guessing an injured ankle
before like those don't ever
it doesn't feel like they go away and
all it takes is
you roll the ankle again or you know
anthony davis
gets injured again and then you're out
for three or four games that's that's
how you get
knocked off here you want rhythm and
chemistry
at this time of year especially going
into the playoffs
and let's face it injuries are a part of
the game
we get it um and i i look at
tampa bay buccaneers they got right
they got healthy at the right time
towards the end of the season when
everyone was getting banged up
tom brady and his gang of warriors got
right
got healthy and started to click and
play at the right time and
onto the super bowl and they win it and
it's not a light switch basketball is
not a light switch you can turn on and
turn off you have great talent don't get
me wrong that's
lakers when whole and healthy
my opinion they're the two favorites but
you've got to have some type of rhythm
and you've got to have some type of
chemistry going into the playoffs
i think it was a huge win for the lakers
for their psyche
yeah because everyone's talking about
playing and
i still think once lebron comes back
they will be better but it's not a light
switch
and like you said you are messing with
danger because of the way steph
if they end up playing golden state in
that playing game remember
i mean that one loss that that can prove
a lot of things and steph can get hot
and put up 50 on you in a heartbeat
so you've got to be careful and you've
got to try to find a way to get that
rhythm
and chemistry going we were talking
about russell westbrook that he's on the
verge of
breaking oscar's record for triple
doubles in a career
i was wondering how magic johnson would
be in today's nba
oh my god but he'd be shooting more
threes though right red she'd be
shooting that set shot three
he probably would be but think about
that at six nine a six
nine point guard um when there's no hand
checking
and freedom of movement that's the two
things
taken from the 80s and 90s basketball
versus the 2000s
freedom of movement being able to you
know not hand check
and you can float anywhere you want
magic johnson
playing downhill every time there's a
missed shot
i think he would have been brilliant
yeah because
he had a couple of years i think he
mostly averaged like 24 one year when
kareem was gone but he was like a 19
points 11 assist guy
and and that's where we get caught up in
stats and people say you know russell
westbrook is maybe the second or third
greatest point guard of all time
i want to know what my point guard does
when i need him to do you know what it
is a point guard supposed to do
john stockton you know what did he
average 15
14 15 or 16 yeah like but what did he do
when he needed to do it
that's what russell hasn't given us
westbrook is a
you know statistical anomaly it's just
when he's been on a big stage
he hasn't performed that's where i
always say that's the difference in
being a
great point guard and one of the
all-time great point guards
russ is fascinating to watch but can you
do this on a big stage
and maybe the pressure's off because
washington is not a great team or high
expectations but
him and bradley beal in a in a short
series
they could be i mean they could probably
uh you know steal
a series from somebody hard out
hard out with those two guys because
both guys
they can win you ball games and it's
always going to be a dog fight and a
struggle
and like you know people always want to
knock russell
because of the triple doubles you know
and it's almost what have you done for
me lately we know that you're putting up
these numbers but you're
in the 9th or 10th spot in the east
but i i say that to these people i would
much rather want to have a guy who's
ready to run through a brick wall like
russell westbrook who gives you effort
on
every single play does he have flaws
absolutely but playing hard is the
number one thing
that you don't see a lot of great
players do a lot of great players have
talent but they don't play hard
all the time and it's true he does
russ plays too hard sometimes he plays
too hard right i know
he plays two hearts i know i would much
rather have russell westbrook than a lot
of these other guys
that take plays off he's reggie miller
the hall of famer turner
sports nba analyst um the pelicans
david griffin got fined fifty thousand
dollars talking about how
zion is officiated and i i gave a couple
of stats here on him that
nobody has had their shot blocked more
than zion 131 times he's had a shot
blocked this year
but nobody scores more in the paint like
he's
he's 300 points i think more than the
joker and the greek freak so
he gets in like he's a smaller
version of shaq i i don't think they
know how to officiate him here reg but
zion to his credit did say i hope
i get to the point where i get those
calls he didn't criticize the official
now he's got a broken finger here
how do you officiate him and is it
similar to the way
shaq was officiated somewhat similar
i think with shaq shaq was so much
bigger than
everyone else and so much more powerful
it almost wasn't fair and i i think what
david griffin and the pelicans and to
zion's credit
what they're doing is just planting a
seed for years to come
because until he develops that outside
jump shot
and you and i we've talked about this on
this show many of times
if they can't solve what he's doing in
the paint
if it ain't broke don't fix it and i
think all he wants to do is plant seeds
in the official
until he gets a jump shot because that's
the only way really he's scoring
is in the paint and that's driving and
the reason why
he gets his shot blocked the most is
because that's where his bread and
butter is
that's where his candy land is is in the
paint so of course he's gonna get
his shot blocked more because he's not
taking jump shots
he's shooting in the paint and i wonder
what would you what would you tell him
to work on
i would have him number one a face up
from 15 to 18 feet
a catch and a couple jab steps to freeze
the defense
and to knock down that shot or a one
dribble left or a one dribble right
pull up jump shot because then you're
gonna have the defense guessing
because after that we've seen his first
step his first step is unbelievable
we've seen his spin move after his first
serve he likes to go left
spin and then bring that you know the
arms up that's probably
where he got a broken finger because he
exposes the ball
what i would do one dribble pull up left
one dribble pull up right
now you keep the defense guessing now
you can work on your spin move
and you have the defense at your mercy
we also talked about luka doncic
that uh he got tossed you know in the
game against cleveland for the uh
the flagrant but uh the technicals are a
really
big concern for me because star players
can't
they can't be baited they shouldn't be
baited
and here's luca with 15 technicals
dwight howard's the only player with
more he's got 16.
uh so what advice would you give luke a
doncic on
trying to avoid getting involved in
these and complaining
well here's the thing because i was a
complainer and i
that's why i'm asking you a small
complaint
you never want to put your team in
jeopardy because they didn't have when
you got a certain amount of
technicals when i played you got
suspended the game
that would hurt the mavericks that would
hurt your team
so you can't put yourself in that
position uh you know look
having played for rick carlos carl
ricardo goes to bat
for his his players and i would go
to if i'm carlyle i would go to luca and
say look
let me handle the officials let me get
tossed
let me get on them because what he's
doing now
i'm over time could eventually hurt his
team
because every play it seems like when he
doesn't get the call
number one he's in the backcourt having
conversations with the official while
the play is going on
and he's doing his team a disservice by
not getting back getting back into plays
because you have players who are
irritants you know that's
that's their patrick's job yes but luca
can't let
rasheed wallace you played against
rasheed it felt like anything bothered
rasheed
uh draymond green is is baitable it
feels like
and and great players you you have to
use it as motivation
and uh it doesn't feel like luca does
that and the
in the type of game he has think about
this luca has the basketball for the
mavs i would say
85 90 of the time your game can do your
speaking for you if you think a player
is beating you or
trash talking or whatever you've got the
ball in your hands
you're calling all the plays take it out
on them and their team
you can't get caught up in words take it
out with your play
embarrass them that's how you get your
pay back what was it uh
last friday was the anniversary of your
game against the knicks
eight points in nine seconds yes it was
like it was yesterday did the hall of
fame ask for anything
from that game i believe they asked for
either a jersey or my shoes which they
have
i gave it to them yes where are the
socks
i don't know in a laundry bin see i
would like the socks
that would be great how many items does
the hall of fame have of yours
shoes a full jersey they probably have a
game basketball
wristband and that's it
but those are all based off of what so
the one game
yeah certain games performances like
that game
um the jordan hitting the shot over
jordan i'm sure they asked for something
look it's an honor when they call and
say hey you know we're thinking about
displaying this at the hall of fame
um so of course you the pacers send it
off which was cool i think those two
games are the
are the two things that where they've
asked for stuff but you see greg anthony
right all the time yes you see greg
anthony
and greg is the guy who was trying to
guard you and you kind of
nudged him and he fell to the floor glad
you said it the correct word was nudged
yeah you know
but but do you can you bring this up
or does would greg anthony ever bring
this up to you that you
it's funny you know i've called a couple
games with greg
and uh we'll see something during the
course of the game
and he'll bring it up like it's 1995.
like i shoved him out of a
moving car or something like great you
were on your
you were on your way down anyways my
friend
so my incidental contact
shouldn't have really even mattered a
little bit
but i just like you know when i went
like that right away i thought i was
going to get the call but when i didn't
hear a whistle
and anthony mason i'm telling you
god rest his soul he threw me the best
pass mark jackson never could have grown
i mean it hit me right here in my pop
right in my shooting pocket right into
my
i mean one dribble behind the three it
was
it was launched anthony mason was scary
scared that knicks team was scary i mean
people want to talk about the bad voice
and rightfully so
some of those some of those characters
on the bad boys were a little loose
charles oakley anthony mason i mean greg
anthony
uh john starks a lot of these guys had
screws loose
too thank god i had my davis boys who
weren't all there
uh lasalle thompson wasn't all there
sam mitchell not all there so we could
kind of like
go toe-to-toe with the knicks but
anthony mason was a scary dude man
who's the guy that you worried about
after a game
that you played against
two and i love them to death
vernon maxwell who's one of my good
friends
mad max mad max because you didn't know
if he was going to come into the locker
room and ask for an
autograph or y'all were going to be
scrapping in
in the middle of the visiting team's
locker room
and alvin robinson i mean alvin i i knew
after my rookie year
when john long came to me and said never
and i mean absolutely never reg say a
word
to albert robinson just let him play his
game if he fouls you hard
just say good don't don't even look at
him
because he his eyes are steely black
don't even talk to him so he didn't know
what you were going to get between alvin
and
and mad max well you know love them both
now
mark jackson tells that story about
alvin robertson you're playing dice
and he said they know he's cheating and
everybody's afraid to call him on it
because they were worried that alvin was
just not a guy you messed with i
i love that they they had to continue to
lose money
because they couldn't call out on
cheating
he had loaded dice
[Laughter]
crazy just crazy oh god
and you survived i survived i'm here
speaking with you and my dad
yeah uh all right well so you got you
don't find out your assignment until
later today
i think it's either portland at miami
or it's portland and uh the phoenix suns
but you're not traveling again i'll be
on you're not traveling
not traveling yet right now remotely
oh well then it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it doesn't matter it
doesn't matter it's still remotely
people
i i just saw where duncan robinson is in
line for 20 million
a year contract
really yeah no
that's good that's good imagine if
you're 20 years younger
reg i will never fault guys for making
money that's what this game is all about
the guys we are before me they paved the
way so i could
make a living and that's what we did now
for the duncan robinsons of the year 20
million
yeah pretty good for a shooter go get it
thank you reg
uh thank you theodore i love you
talk to you soon that's uh the hall of
famer reggie aloysius miller
jr the third we'll take a break back
after this